let's hear from some people in the
audience these are the most important
people without you there is no show we
take calls via Discord on the Friday
show at davidpackman.com
Discord and we will start today with
Chris from Massachusetts Chris what is
going on my friend
hi David it's so wonderful to finally be
able to speak with you I had two quick
questions that actually don't have to do
with politics and start us off sure
that's allowed
first um I know that you are a fan of
tango music of course I was wondering if
you were into any other forms of Latin
American music from other parts of the
world do you like salsa Mariachi any of
those you know I'm not huge on let me
put it this way I like all of it I just
don't know enough about it to be able to
name any artists it's sort of like I
know when I go to certain restaurants or
events
they have music of all of these styles
that I like but it's not like I take
time out of my day to go and investigate
artists or bands or anything like that
but sure I mean listen other than
country and hardcore heavy metal uh I'll
go for most stuff you know
ah fantastic fantastic thank you and my
last quick question is
I loved him he was the best Chris asking
what happened to
Pedro
from
Colombia yeah we just haven't heard from
him and I honestly it feels like years
for Chris
oh well that's all I have for you thank
you so much for taking my call all right
Chris from Massachusetts with a number
of questions in a number of languages
and we love to see it let's go to Harry
from Chicago Illinois Harry from Chicago
welcome to the David Pacman show how may
I serve you today sir
can you hear me yes
oh excellent excellent so I used to call
in as uh Harry from Columbus I don't
know if you have any recollection of
that I've recently moved to Chicago
um you know after some brief inspiration
from you actually
wow I I hold on you moved from Columbus
to Chicago because of something I said
in part in part you know I wanted to
move anyway but you know just some stuff
that you said really put me over the
edge and why Chicago did have I sung its
Praises before
no I mean not necessarily Chicago so
much as getting out of a red State and
going into a blue State I gotcha and are
you enjoying that
yeah I am greatly I am I haven't driven
on a highway in like two weeks now I
think my brain is finally healing a
little bit that's good um but it's been
really good well to any extent that you
want to thank me I will accept the
praise thank you well I mean I know you
used to also live in Western
Massachusetts is that correct yeah
I went to college there you know about
Holyoke yes yes I do
okay did you pronounce it Holyoke or
Holyoke no no no I you know I'm not into
this whole hoyoke thing I pronounce it
Holyoke now remember I'm from Argentina
and I only lived in that region for a
for a time and never in Holyoke but I
pronounce it Holyoke
yeah it takes time to learn the language
like Amherst and uh okay uh so my my
question about politics after you know
last week's rulings all the bad scotus
rulings that in my opinion of course
um how do you feel about scotus it's not
it's something that it engages in
specifically is judicial review right uh
ultimately determined in I think was
Marbury V Madison way back when that
scotus could do this now other countries
other democracies they don't have this
kind of judicial review
um do you consider it something bad do
you think more Justice is is the problem
people on the left have criticized that
yeah I think judicial review is needed
to be a check and balance what do you
what do you think about you know
judicial review of law that has passed
so listen obviously I am not a legal
expert so I speak to the political
implications here I do believe that
there is a degree to which judicial
review meaning the power of a court to
say this law that was passed no good
it's unconstitutional to some degree it
can be undemocratic the nine justices
are not elected and they can say well
we're overriding the popular sovereignty
of states and okay but sometimes they
may be making the right decision and we
might want it you can say judicial
review is unreliable because as you're
pointing out it depends to some degree
on personal views and biases we know
that a left-wing Supreme Court versus a
right-wing Supreme Court is likely to
come down in different places on many
important and controversial decisions
you can argue that judicial review is
unnecessary in that there are better
ways to protect certain rights either by
referenda or media scrutiny or you know
but but at the same time sometimes you
can't there's the argument that it's
counterproductive because then when
there's judicial review that goes
counter to the party that is in power
there's a backlash effect where the
party in power says all right well we're
going to now figure out some other way
to do the thing so that we can act you
know like Biden figuring out a different
way to do student loans so I think that
there are really good arguments against
judicial review but where I am trying to
focus most based on my audience and what
I do
is right we we have to remember
that if Hillary Clinton had defeated
Donald Trump a lot of what we have seen
from this Supreme Court would never have
happened it is undeniable at this point
this is not to shame anybody this is not
to insult anybody I am doing a show that
is based around electoral politics we
have an election coming up we need to
beat people over the head metaphorically
with the reality that we may again have
this sort of situation depending on who
wins in November of 2024 and that
everything that's happened the justices
that are now on the court Roe v Wade all
of these different things if Hillary
Clinton gets to put a few people on the
court instead of Donald Trump based on
winning in 2016 we have a completely
different Supreme Court it's not a
solution it doesn't answer a lot of
these questions but it's a reminder
about the importance of these elections
yeah I I agree that I don't think I
don't have any delusions that judicial
review is going away anytime soon
correct and I I agree if you know four
out of nine of the justices are you know
were either stolen elected from
presidents who didn't win the popular
vote I agree that electoralism is
probably the best way to be to beat the
monster of the scotus even though in the
200 year history of our country it's
been mostly a right-wing institution
that has dominated us you know with all
that in mind we can still hope uh thanks
for taking my call David all right Harry
from Chicago great to hear from you just
a reminder for people waiting to chat
with me you must have your name and
location in your nickname if you just
have one or the other or just a nickname
or that sort of thing uh you are not
going to be called on it's sort of just
like can folks follow basic directions
we're trying to have some filter so we
try to get quality calls so we do uh we
do enforce that we do enforce that
one of our sponsors is yada the Free
banking app that makes it fun to save
money just like a regular bank account
you can withdraw your money anytime and
it's fully FDIC insured when you keep
your money in a yada bank account you'll
have a shot at winning nightly cash
prizes ranging from two cents to a
million dollars for every twenty five
dollars in your account you get one
recurring ticket to the nightly prize
drawing so if you deposit a hundred
dollars you get four tickets every
single night without needing to make any
more deposits yada also offers some
great budgeting features the possibility
of early paydays a debit card that
rewards you with up to one hundred
percent cash back and tickets on every
purchase yada members have already won
over 15 million dollars so say goodbye
to the traditional savings account with
the minimal interest rate free economics
have described prize linked savings
accounts like a no lose Lottery download
the app now start saving for a chance to
win big with yada the app where savings
meets excitement go to with yada.com
Pacman the link is in the description